all right it's time for Friday feedback
the mailbag the Friday Feed Bag someone
actually wrote to me saying it should
really be called Friday Apple bags which
relates to a whole other thing from the
vaccine era anyway we don't even need to
get into that that's probably outside
the scope of today's conversation if you
have something to say and many of you do
you can email info at davidpackman.com
please keep them polite not everyone we
look at today will be polite be aware
that as you are furiously typing
comments on YouTube they might be
selected and end up in the Friday
feedback you never know and Reddit posts
and so on and so forth it all might end
up there all right let's start with
today's first one from YouTube user John
Cherokee who says yeah Tucker Carlson
was an American hero and I hope he will
get his own show where they can't fire
him because his message is very
important in addition to that Taylor
green is an American hero she's
basically standing virtually alone
basically virtually alone in Congress
defending the rights of the American
people this is a big fan not only of
Tucker Carlson but of Marjorie Taylor
green not a single um a punctuation
element
in this entire message unless you count
the apostrophe on she's but certainly no
uh sentences
um listen this is one of those things
where we all have to pick our battles
and the battles I pick on a podcast and
YouTube channel
and the battles you pick at the
Thanksgiving table and that your sibling
picks at the Memorial Day barbecue which
is upcoming right whatever battles we
all pick might be different and for me I
am not now going to choose the Battle of
trying to convince someone who believes
that Marjorie Taylor green and Tucker
Carlson are the height of American
patriotism that they are wrong that is
not a battle that I am going to pick
right now so we're going to move on but
these folks exist and that's always
important to remember
DD 2023 DD says LOL I can't believe you
all are applauding high taxes for
everyone in some obscure version of
fairness that doesn't help you at all in
fact it damages you when the company you
work for moves to a different country to
operate or Cuts costs by changing your
health care benefits to a cheaper one or
flat out lays you off because you aren't
very efficient so dumb you know
I uh understand
and I'm in agreement with the reality
that if any tax gets too high it starts
to have an impact that is usually not uh
ideal and with most policy this isn't
unique to taxes in general with policy
in general with life
when you think about the extreme Tales
of normal distribution you start to see
distortions take for example like
exercise if you are completely sedentary
and sit all day at a desk and then at
home and then in your car and then
watching TV do no physical exercise
you're on one tail end of physical
exercise and that's bad for you on the
other hand if you become completely
obsessed with exercise to the point that
you can't hold the job and you're you're
destroying Your Body by working out 18
hours a day and sleeping for six or
whatever right at the extremes of these
bell curves there are problems and so
zero percent taxes would be a problem
because we can't have functioning
infrastructure
um and then 100 taxes as well and so
we're all kind of operating in the gray
area
but what is missed by lots of these
people who write stuff like this are
they don't get that most corporations
are passed through entities like
s-corporations llc's and others and that
the so-called business tax rate from
which there are endless loopholes
applies to C corporations
but again I'm sort of like trying to
explain this to somebody who's not
willing to listen anyway but I am in
agreement that taxes shouldn't be too
high and how we Define that probably
differs uh between us Rocky Road said
look for real
as a 100 Die Hard Trump supporter I'd
like one of David Pacman's audience to
explain this to me
how has Biden's first term been anything
other than a complete disaster I'm not
trying to troll I'm not looking to
insult I'm just 100 puzzled by this well
I like to apply something called the
burden of proof in these situations
I would love to hear from Rocky Road
what elements of Joe Biden's presidency
make it a disaster inflation reduction
act reasonably sized does some good
things changes to student lending small
changes to Health Care access
um uh stock market is doing fine
unemployment lowest since 1969 inflation
coming down
um no new Wars as they always like to
say you may say well but Russia invaded
Ukraine okay yeah but Biden didn't start
that war okay uh you know you make the
case make the case for the Biden
disaster because I look around and I see
wages up 4.4 percent over the last year
inflation down stocks okay new jobs
things seem like sort of all right
nothing's perfect we haven't solved a
whole bunch of systemic and structural
issues but sort of like seems like
things are going okay
uh this was a meme posted to our
subreddit I don't know how many of you
have been following the Stephen Crowder
situation where Stephen Crowder
um he's a right-wing talker
and he's getting a divorce and
surveillance of security camera footage
was released in which he's berating his
wife and it okay
here is conservative struggling
with conflicting Notions the Stephen
Crowder video is an invasion of his
privacy and shouldn't be blocked and
should be blocked rather versus arguing
that Hunter Biden's penis pictures
should be publicly available yeah
they've really gotten themselves into
now of course you know what they will
say right sometimes on the left we think
we really got them now we really got him
they will simply say that Hunter the
hunter Biden laptop story which included
the penis pictures
is more politically relevant
to American politics than what Stephen
Crowder has to say because Hunter is Joe
Biden's son or whatever we've already
debunked it in the sense that Hunter
Biden has nothing to do with the Biden
Administration and Stephen Crowder also
has nothing to do with the Biden
Administration so a little something for
everyone there
Descartes walks into a pub
says who could have predicted
stripping away rights and banning books
with Drive Away voters yeah this is
tongue-in-cheek but it really didn't
seem that Florida Republicans and other
Republicans understood
that the anti-woke Crusade that they are
waging isn't super popular with much
much of America
that much of a majority of America is
coming down on the side of Disney on the
side of drag shows existing and you can
choose whether you bring your kid or not
um dealing with structural problems that
affect trans people most of the country
is on the so-called woke side and so as
I've said before
a lot of these are good ways to raise
some money
in primaries in local races but as far
as National campaigns it's not at all
evident to me
that this anti-woke approach book
Banning canceling all the stuff the
right is doing
is going to work well but we will see we
have an election coming up from YouTube
23 mistakes says perhaps telling half
the voters that they no longer make
decisions about their own bodies has
something to do with falling poll
numbers same idea you look at abortion
you look at polling on Roe v Wade and
you see that since Roe the Roe v Wade
air started started 50 years ago support
for abortion being legal in most cases
has only gone up and it reached its
highest point right around the time that
the Supreme Court did away with Roe v
Wade and it did play a role in the
November of 2022 midterms maybe not as
big a role as it would have played if it
had been closer in time to the election
it was you know some months but
you look at the polling and you look at
opinion surveys about what Americans
want and you see most Americans do
believe abortion should be legal most of
the time so then why would you have an
entire political movement social
conservatism based around ending and
banning abortion doesn't seem to make
sense
we will see if they suffer even more as
a result of that
in 2024 and of course I hope that they
do consequences for actions it's a
beautiful thing lastly Pam Hall
says very disappointed in Pac-Man who
had endorsed Williamson on another of
his podcasts why he is throwing her
under the bus now over a gaff is the
real question
please
criticize me for things I said I never
endorsed Marianne Williamson my position
on Marianne Williamson has not changed
since I learned about her since I became
woke to Marianne Williamson very nice
person
has great empathy and shares many of my
broader ideals and
is not interesting to me as a
presidential candidate for many reasons
that I've gone over including lack of EX
of relevant experience in a number of
different areas previous statements that
I find completely antithetical to my
world view about everything from
depression to other things
I don't know you know the problem is
I simplify simplify simplify to try to
be to make it impossible to be
misunderstood
but then I don't provide enough context
so that causes a problem and then when I
go Nuance expand Nuance context people
don't listen to the whole thing and then
they go you endorsed her on another
podcast when what are you talking about
what what on Earth are you talking about
endorsed in what sense what does that
even mean so listen Marianne Williamson
should run she is running it's not up to
me anybody who wants to run should run I
would like I would prefer the DNC have
debates they're not going to it has
nothing to do with me the DNC is not
going to have debates because why would
you do something that could jeopardize
the campaign of whoever is sort of like
the de facto nominee doesn't matter who
it is they're not going to have debates
I would like to see debates and you
would just have to figure out what
polling threshold would be required to
make it into the democratic debate would
it be four percent six percent eight
percent in the polling I don't know but
you'd have to find some threshold and I
would love to see a debate with Joe
Biden Marianne Williamson you know Bobby
Kennedy Jr to the extent that he's a
Democrat and he's running and has
polling support which he does in in some
polls put him on a stage that's great I
think it's fantastic am I supporting
Marianne Williamson for president no I'm
not but that doesn't mean I don't think
she should run or that she should be
silenced or whatever the case may be
criticize me if you disagree with what I
actually believe
not random usings that are about things
I've never said
info davidpackman.com you might be
featured in next week's Friday Feed Bag
feedback Friday
Etc uh we've got a great bonus show for
you today sign up at joinpakman.com we
will see you then or Monday